und jetzt sprechen wir genau darüber
auch mit anton hofreiter dem
grünen-bundestagsabgeordneten herzlich
willkommen beim live hofreiter wir waren
also gerade mit unserem reporter dort in
diesem stahlwerk vielleicht ganz kurz
dort bleiben denn dieses oft stahlwerk
von mario pohl auch nachdem sie gerade
erst aus der ukraine aus kiew
zurückgekehrt sind hier nach deutschland
wie erleben sie diesen kampf dieses
aushungern lassen dieses stahlwerks von
mario pohl und glauben sie daran dass ja
wenigstens die zivilisten dort irgendwie
heil herauskommen werden tageslicht
wieder bekommen
ist ihnen kriegsverbrecher ist und diese
kriegsverbrechen auch gezielt einsetzt
um die menschen einzuschüchtern
und ich habe große sorge das ist nicht
gelingt die russische seite dazu zu
bringen zumindestens zuzulassen dass die
zivilisten evakuiert werden denn in ihre
reportage ist ja gerade geschildert
worden was das zynische kalkül
von der russischen armee ist nämlich je
mehr zivilisten im stahlwerk sind desto
schneller gehen die wasser und
nahrungsmittel vor werte für alle
ausgaben wiederfinden dieser situationen
jetzt da auch unsere schweren waffen
helfen kann
ich fürchte dass die dafür nicht schnell
genug eintreffen außerdem ist mario
köhler sehr stark umziehen aber nichts
desto weniger müssen wir alles dafür tun
dass selbst kriegspartei zu werden um
die ukraine zu unterstützen und das r
wünsche ich mir dass der
bundestagsbeschluss jetzt sehr sehr
zügig umgesetzt wird ob dass es nicht
nur bei der gepa langsam bleibt sondern
dass deutlich mehr noch geliefert werden
kann in unserer industrie hat noch
merken angebot was konkret herr
hofreiter
das ist bekannt industrie und anträge
gestellt unter anderem als am
bekanntesten jetzt für leopard 1 panzer
und hier male anzahl das gegenargument
dass die bundeswehr die selbst braucht
hier nicht weil das material ist das bei
der industrie selbst steht ortes
weiteres argument die ukrainischen
soldaten könnten nicht damit umgehen
wenn was erst in der ukraine war
mit einem verdeutlicht wie
paternalistisch ja im grunde beleidigen
dieses argument empfunden wird weil die
menschen in ukraine zu recht haben
unsere militär kämpft seit wochen helden
auf gegen die russische armee die
wüssten sehr wohl über mit waffen umgeht
und die kämpfen ja für frieden und
freiheit nicht nur für die ukraine
sondern für ganz europa entsprechen sich
auch hier jetzt wieder bei bild live
massive weitere waffenlieferungen noch
aus über die zugesagten hinaus sind sie
eigentlich auch für eine massive
aufrüstung der bundeswehr aus voller
grüner überzeugung
wir müssen die bundeswehr deutlich
besser ausstatten da hat man in der
vergangenheit fehler gemacht da muss man
ehrlicherweise sagen ich habe da fehler
gemacht ich habe dinge anders
eingeschätzt ich dachte auch
irrtümlicherweise dass man mir
produzieren wer ist da verhandeln kann
johann zum glück immer wegen nord stream
24 hätten stärker auf die osteuropäer
müssten auch nichts desto weniger muss
trotzdem zukünftig versucht werden mit
all diejenigen die guten willens sind
dass abrüstung und diplomatie wieder
eine chance bekommt ich sehe bloß mit
einer imperialen diktator putin ist es
nicht wirklich wenn man erst mal
verdeutlicht seine imperialen anderes
pläne werden zum scheitern führen kann
man eben auch verdeutlichen durch die
unabhängigkeit von russischer energie
und öl embargo das tut weh das sagt
robert habeck wem tut es weh
tut insbesondere russland w damit
russland hat im letzten jahr die
vierfache menge an geld doch unverdient
als wir doch erdgas dank der guten
arbeit unseres wirtschaftsministers
tanker guten arbeit und robert habeck
sind ja bereits auf einen anteil von nur
noch zwölf prozent bei erdöl lässt sich
viel viel leichter transportieren wie
erdgas und deswegen es dringend
notwendig dass wir möglichst schnell ein
komplettes ölembargo gegen
russland verhängen um das
verbrecherische putin von den
geldzuflüssen aufzuschneiden erleben sie
in diesen tagen herr hofreiter wie sie
die regierung auch treiben zu
entscheidungen treiben wie die
opposition das macht aber sie wie sie
auch ihre eigenen reihen vorantreiben
sie sind gefragt worden in den
vergangenen tagen ob das hier zur rache
ist auch an ihrer eigenen partei an
ihren eigenen leuten und sie haben
gesagt sie hätten das mal geprüft hätten
sich gefragt ob das so ist und werden
zum ergebnis gekommen ist keine rache
aber können sie jetzt ganz ehrlich frei
reden seitdem sie nicht mehr
fraktionschef sind frei ihre meinung
sagen frei forderungen stellen
selbstverständlich ist man als parlament
freier aber ich glaub es zu dieser
regierung jeder demokratie und einem
parlament gut wenn parlamentarier laut
und deutlich ihre meinung kundtun und es
hat sich ja vieles in die in meinen
augen richtige richtung bewegt und ich
muss ehrlicherweise sagen wenn man sich
allein weiter die schrecklichen bilder
die auch in ihrem bericht gerade was die
menschen schlimm es in mario pohl
erleben sich anschaut dann zu glauben
dass da vor allem um persönliche
beweggründe ich weiß nicht das ja
irgendwie schon die vermutung bisschen
daneben ja jungs und mädels so nannte
der kanzler adressiert an all die die
nicht mit jeder entscheidung
einverstanden sind er sagte das gehört
zur führung der zu sagte olaf scholz
dass man dann eben auch gegen diese
jungs und mädels handelt er hat sich
dafür ordentlich kritik eingefangen
fühlen sie sich angesprochen sind sie
einer dieser jungs und fanden sie diese
formulierung arrogant vom kanzler
ich ja wir leben in so schwierigen
zeiten der krank versteht unter massiven
druck der ereignisse wie alle die sich
dafür verantwortlich fühlen es geht
einem er selbst sogar auf zweifelt und
habe das was man konnte wirklich das
richtige ist das sind würde ich solche
überhaupt nicht überbewerten was ich mir
wünsche ist dass deutschland ein abstand
stärkstes und wirtschafts mächtigstes
land innerhalb der europäischen union
wenn es dann wie in der vergangenheit
mit sanktionen geht nennt er bei den
letzten dabei ist wenn es um energie in
bar wo geht nicht er bei den letzten
dabei ist und man so machen lieferung
geht hier nicht zögern sondern in ganz
europa wird erwartung an uns
herangetragen gibt es große hoffnung
gegenüber deutschland und wird gesagt
ihr müsst mehr tun und das sind wir
nicht sehr sehr froh dass immerhin jetzt
gestern dieser antrag mit einer ganz
breiten mehrheit im bundestag
verabschiedet worden ist es
beeindruckende hofreiter wie klar sie
derzeit sind in der deutschen politik
wie klar auch viele grünen sind in
sachen waffenlieferungen haben sie sich
nach ihrem besuch in kiew mal gefragt
wie würde ich eigentlich handeln wenn
ich in der ukraine wäre als mann würden
sie schießen würden sie waffen tragen
ich weiß es nicht das finde ich sehr
sehr schwer zu beurteilen wenn man nicht
selbst in der situation ist
es ist ja bekannt dass sie in südamerika
schon die eine oder andere
auseinandersetzung erlebt habe aber ich
finde das sieht man erst dann wenn man
selber in der situation ist man muss
ehrlicherweise sagen in der ukraine
haben wir zum beispiel mit mitglied aus
dem verteidigungsausschuss gesprochen
eine relativ junge frau die wir dort
getroffen haben die kam direkt von der
front und die ist jetzt an die front
zurückgegangen also da gibt es eine
ganze reihe von frauen
nicht nur im zivilen bereich helden auch
das leisten sondern auch direkt gehen ja
in der tat danke herzlich für das
gespräch bei bild leif anton hofreiter
der grüne bundestagsabgeordnete danke